professor GN viswanatha bangalore how
can we further promote science education
in india well i think the answer is in
the to sort of come on board my geo set
program because this is utilizing the
internet to make available to teachers
wherever they are the genius of all the
teachers in the world and I think we've
manifestly failed certainly in the West
in science education and I think we
should recognize that the Internet has a
lot of advantages which might be able to
fill the gaps enough of fill the attend
to some of the problems that we have it
certainly can't happen can't harm it
there's this fantastic technology what
is the optimum way to use it now in the
case of India and all countries we must
make an effort to get the internet into
every school not to all the kids I mean
yeah but they can have it too but I want
the teacher to have access to the day
global cache of inflation well the phone
went so i was just finishing off about
india and I as I said I think it's
absolutely vital that we get a the
internet into the teachers laptop on and
they can then have everything everything
or access to this great cache of
educational experience that teachers
have assembled and not just in India but
all parts of the world partly because I
want to see an improvement in rational
thinking they're not a lot of it around
at the moment and that's vital if we're
to solve the massive problems that we
face I mean I
I've often said that knowledge can't
guarantee good decisions but common
sense suggests that wisdom is not a
likely consequence of ignorance and
there's a massive amount of ignorance
around at the moment